c'est peut-être bien qu'on avance les
gars non on va t'en fous tu à chaque
fois il fait ça lui en fait c'est pas à
croquer tissait que pour avancer j'ai
fait des petits câlins comme ça et après
ils avancent mais le pire c'est quand
même là tu vois il se lève et des fois
on fait vraiment mais genre de m
tu vois et et voilà tu vois genre ça
doug cooke dit on y va
libère demi-tour à l'est non non
non c'est bien très bien ça m'appelle
thibault j'ai 26 ans et ça fait un an un
an et demi que je fais du dock city
[Musique]
je vois comme des potes porte peut-être
paraître bizarre parce que c'est des
chiens meiway pour moi c'est en masse
balader avec des potes pendant une heure
et puis après je les ramène quand
clairement le taf c'est tu prends un
chien tu le balade d'une heure tu joues
avec tu t'en occupes tu ramasses s'ils
font ramasser quoi évidemment pour pas
laissés dans la rue on a 12 pieds ici je
vieillis tu dis bonjour à ses vagues et
ça c'est doug c'est un labrador de
quatre ans c'est un peu la star de tik
tok corse et des bois et après il ya eu
baer qui a 8 ans voilà qui est un basset
hound ah bah non
le boudin surface s'est décidé à avancer
tu as vu mr ça fait comment petite amie
de bas je faisais des vidéos sur
instagram et les gens en fait dit qui
fait les scories de chien et il ya eu
tip top qui a débarqué un peu près au
même moment et je fais une vidéo du coup
avec doug et la vidéo à la fonctionné je
me suis dit vas-y bouton va continuer
dans ce délire là quoi les gens qui font
recette pour le cloud
il est charismatique et il se suffit à
lui-même
j'ai pas tu le vois tes bras je crois qu
a pas vraiment d'explication
il est magique ce choc lundi guy la
balle là là je sais pas ce qui lui
arrive et là d'après une petite étoile
de mario elle va s'envoler à les bus à
bâle a pris la cale et des prêtres aux
lions de montbert c'est bien on a bien
avancé sur 20 mètres là c'est cool c'est
ma mère qui m'a dit et pourquoi tu
deviendrais pas d'occitan parce que du
coup bah je tu as fait pour des libéraux
et des fois c'était un peu chaud à la
fin du mois je me suis dit buzz y
carrément des fois j'essaie de faire des
système de contrepoids ou par exemple ou
à la basse et 12 quartiers au moment
j'en ai une part de tirer je me suis il
faut que je trouve une solution
du coup en fait je mets des laisses
comme cela tu as fait un sort pas la
renommée je les croise juge d'auxerre
mais en fait comme ça quand doug tir
satire hubert et quand il veut partir ça
tire tous qu en fait ceux qui se
baladent c'est même plus loin
ah ouais il faut être patient faut être
calme peut vraiment être clean si tu
t'énerves façon ça va mal se passer et
les chiens je me dis quand même il
arriva à chier alors que je le tiens au
bout d'une laisse franchement à justin
la merde des copains et je ne sais pas
au début c'était pas évident j'avais
vraiment un problème avec ça et enfin
j'ai un problème oui et non tu vas me
des buts un peu dégoûté et puis à dire
tu si fait non franchement je visais
toujours pas souvent c'est avant que
j'allais george iii ma respiration
jemelle masse comme ça et oblige iv et
après j'essaie de trouver une poubelle
et et là franchement je leur donne pas
le choix tu vois genre qu'ils sont la
norme et timo je vais traîner non non là
je tire je me cache' manger ta merde
dans la mort je vais jeter ce à quoi tu
as la palme du chien le plus lent de
paname hummer à les loulous
ça tu sentes la vie elle est dure pour
lui quoi il porte le problème de la
planète sur le dos le loup mais tu vois
comme il est pas bête
et la voilà l'humain sorti la croquette
faisons un effort aller au dodo
j'avais l'idée de faire humoriste depuis
tout petit et du coup je me suis dit
c'est quoi je vais essayer de faire
l'école de l'humour fin et coll d'humour
une école d'humour pardon à paris à côté
du coup je faisais des libéraux et j'ai
fait les chiens c'est comme ça que tout
a commencé
moi j'attends juste une chose c'est que
les théâtres et ouvrait que j'aille me
brand des bides dans les comédies club
pour pouvoir faire des blagues
puis bien sûr à côté je vais continuer
de faire du dogsitting parce que
finalement c'est devenu un peu mon sens
c'est mon job mais c'est mon passe temps
l'après-midi quoi puis j'aime bien
passer du temps avec eux donc